You also felt that sort of embedded
inside the shower where the contract
sexual tendencies and so for example,
sometimes you see people who are well
developed.
Men let say,
and we can.
We can also talk about women in this
regard.
Men who've integrated their shadow often
also develop a kind of peculiar grace
that would be a consequence of not only
allowing their aggressive side to step
forward,
but also their,
their feminine and in Compassionate side
that might,
that they may have kept squelched
because of embarrassment about it or
because they'd been harassed for being
weak or any number of things.
So,
but the practical approach for
developing your shadow,
I would say is to contemplate and
consider your resentment and notice what
it says and because your resentment will
also tell you what you have to say.
You know,
so look,
look at what happened at Google this
weekend.
You know,
James Damore wrote that memo and you can
imagine he was pretty angry and perhaps
even somewhat resentful at having to
attend that diversity seminar.
And I'm really just using this as an
example.
But what he did was decide that that
meant that he had something that he had
to say and then look at the consequences
of that man.
It's an absolutely unbelievable.
And so you know,
if you're feeling oppressed at work or
you're oppressed in your life or,
or you know where you're oppressing
yourself,
then you got to notice that you're
feeling oppressed.
Then you have to notice that you're
feeling resentful,
resentful and angry and bitter,
and maybe even like Cain in the story of
Cain and Abel because Cain is sort of
the archetypal bitter man.
And then you have to decide what it is
that you need to do in order to remove
from yourself that bitterness.
And that's usually means that there's
something that you have to say and then
you have to say it because you're sold
depends on it.
And not only does your soul depend on
it.
I would say the fate of the world
depends on it because you know you might
be wrong and then you should be
straightened out.
Maybe you're just being whiny and you
have to talk to somebody about that.
But it may be that you're actually
detecting something wrong,
some tyranny that's directed towards you
and other people,
and it's like your moral obligation to
speak up about it.
And so many workplaces become toxic to
use a terrible cliche,
cliche because the people in the won't
speak up for what they actually want,
or they speak up too late and then
they're all twisted up about it and,
and you know they're torturing other
people because they're so unhappy and so
forth and so on.
So practical approach for developing
your shadow fundamentally is radical.
Honesty and young said that in a genuine
moral effort was a good substitute for
psychotherapy.